تبدو اماكن الترفيه هو الحدائق في العاصمه
كابول هكذا خاليه من السيدات بعد احداث
حضر فرضته طالبان على النساء
البشريه والبشر كلهم بحاجه الى ذلك ويجب
ان يقوم بزيارته هذه الاماكن اما بشكل
شهري او اسبوعين على الرغم من انطاليبان
قامت بفصل الجنسين في المطاعم والمتنزهات
وفي حدائق الترفيه فان المتنزهات والصالات
الرياضيه كانت تعتبر واحده من الاماكن
العامه التي نادرا ما تتواجد فيها النساء
بانه يرجع الى التجاهل بعضهن اوامر الفصل
بين الجنسين وعدم ارتدائه من الحجاب او
غطاء الراس اللازم في حين لم تقدم طالبان
تفاصيل احيال النوع الاجراء الذي سيتم
اتخاذه مع اللواتي لا يطبقن القرار
كانت النساء لا يراعين الحجاب كما كنا لا
يراعين الاصول التي تم الاعلان عنها من
طرف طالبان وبالتالي اضطر الطالبه لمنعهن
واصبحت اماكن الترفيه الان مغلقه امامهن
الاجراء الجديد بحسب المستثمرين في
الاماكن الترفيهيه يقلل بشكل كبير من
زبائن المتنزهات مضيفين انه سيؤثر على
دخلهم في وقت قد استثمر بعضهم ملايين
الدولارات الامريكيه فيها تؤكد طالبان
بانها استخدمت كل جهودها خلال الخمسه عشر
شهرا الماضيه لتفادي اغلاق ابواب اماكن
الترفيه والصالات الرياضيه امام النساء
الا ان اجراءاتها الماضيه لم تكن ناجحه في
هذا الصباح نذر العربيه